my walk is not one for you here my wife
and I are two months away from the birth
of our first child that is [ __ ]
awesome congratulations I want to hear
your opinion on one of the names we have
been favoring first name birdy [ __ ] you
you're not naming a kid birdy you're
full of [ __ ] yeah I don't I don't buy
this I don't buy this at all first name
birdy middle name Allah ull a short from
my grandmother or sulla last name starts
with a G her initials would be B ug bug
is this too weird of a name oh you
[ __ ] hipster [ __ ] no it isn't go
ahead and name your [ __ ] baby birdy
you [ __ ] dope I imagine the DMV
calling her name or a teacher calling
her name and roll call what do you think
you know what I think you don't name a
kid birdy why would you do I don't
understand people who got this did you
never get this [ __ ] kicked out of you
for no [ __ ] reason when you were in
school you're literally giving people a
reason every [ __ ] day to [ __ ] with
your kid why would you do that
give her a pretty name birdy
you know you know why God gives someone
like you sperm that works it's just it's
just I don't understand it I mean you
know was that too harsh this week on
people is birdy is that like a you know
what I gotta look that up right now I
got to look that [ __ ] thing up right
now you got to be [ __ ] [ __ ] me
there's no way is that gonna be like the
new like Kathy birdy then they let's
sweeping the nation birdy that's that's
a golfing term that's what you hit in
badminton burry
girl girl named okay let's see the
history of this birdie meaning of the
name whatever that was Lady Bird Johnson
birdie was until recently a middle-aged
ladies club what birdie was until
recently a middle-aged ladies club
member wearing a bird decorated hat but
now it's just kind of a vintage nickname
think Haiti does that supposed to be
Lucy Josie Oh Josie eyes are going mammy
Millie that's coming back into style in
a big way actress Busy Philipps named
her baby birdy inspired by first lady
Lady Bird Johnson as did soap star Mara
West in an earlier heyday of nicknames
the 1880s birdy was a top 200 name
people who also like birdy also like
Alabama Alfie Alfred Aspen Blanche
Cicely clover Dixie Franklin Hawk who
[ __ ] names a kid Hawk Leonora Oswald
boss when first of all if celebrities
are naming their baby that it's a good
[ __ ] that that's a good one to avoid
oh my God look at these [ __ ] names
Sparrow Remy ransom the [ __ ] name is a
kid Rance Vesper
win WI end where goddammit
Zera to Lucy tou L o u SE Toulouse I
looked at that and that looked my
[ __ ] dyslexia
I just thought tool shed patients who
the [ __ ] irony that I just flipped
out about that
Dixie yeah once you just call her truck
stop [ __ ] Frank there's a normal one
Franklin that's alright Gertrude Jesus
Christ what's she banging someone in the
[ __ ] Gestapo Gretel Cosmo Guthrie
Lottie maple Marilla dude these are
[ __ ] these are [ __ ] white people
douche bag [ __ ] names oh my god
these please a Mortimer India hair on
her on that's like how black people say
heroin Haran he's on that hair on you
can name a [ __ ] they make it a drug a
slang for a drug did these these [ __ ]
names are horrible wait a minute let me
get this popularity okay these are the
popular names I got to keep going with
this podcast this is [ __ ] birdy is
number four 69 on named Barry what the
[ __ ] is name Barry
alright it reached its peak this is like
Casey Kasem the neighbor D reached its
peak in 1882 ranked at 210 yeah and then
by the 40's wait a minute it would
dropped all the way down to the [ __ ]
thousand where it belonged
and her a different name alright let's
enter it didn't me what's a worse
[ __ ] name I can think of what's a
[ __ ] douchey name I hit hipster would
not would name their kid I'm gonna go
with Lampe he just looked over and saw a
lamp see if that's one
no no lamp E is open if you want to be
[ __ ] original how about fridge Fri
DGE it's something a [ __ ] stupid
white person would name their kid we
found 21 results there's no way
anybody's naming that kid fridge
I bet Miltie I'll bet Milt Milt
popularity is 1000% this week that
already seems seem Milt I'm gonna think
of some of the some of the [ __ ] old
singers back in the day it was Engelbert
Humperdinck about a Ebenezer I can't
spell this is in there is e in there
just for the record I'm spelling an e bi
n e a zer
no [ __ ] results for that how go [ __ ]
yourself alright yeah I got I got one
[ __ ] name that comes out here come on
Evan easer a Bernie's are up as I you
spell it
you guys still listening to this boy
named Ebenezer boy named all right
meaning of Ebenezer Evan easer is a name
of a biblical place the stones set up by
Samuel to mark his victory over the
Philistines rather than a person it was
adopted by the British Puritans as the
first name and then exported to America
where it had some early popularity
entering the top 1000 in the 1880s geez
I'd say 1880s was a rough time to be
born not only [ __ ] the scurvy and all
that [ __ ] horseshit had [ __ ] names
like Ebenezer in birdie you can just
feel they're itchy clothes with those
[ __ ] names can you all right I can
babble with this [ __ ] forever all right
that's the podcast for this week
everybody as always if you would like to
donate to the podcast but not spend any
[ __ ] money next time you go to Amazon
just swing by bill bird calm first click
on the merch page and then click on the
amazon link it'll take you over to
Amazon won't cost you any extra money
they'll kick me a little dough for
sending traffic their way and then I
kick 10% of whatever they give me
to the st. Jude's Hospital there you go
that's the podcast for this week go [ __ ]
yourselves I have a great week and don't
name your kid birdy